retirement yes we're here when will you
know it's the end oh man
i'm in a real weird place um
because the one more year chant there
was an assumption fair assumption that
there would be one more year which
implies retirement and
there are moments where i'm like yeah
this feels like the right this could be
the last year it feels right for it to
be the last year
and you know i explained to you kind of
how the season ended and i was really
tired and the way i'm feeling right now
is i'm not so tired and i actually feel
like pretty good physically so that's
like messing with my head a little bit
so i do think once the season starts
and i know it's not like fair
i'm not trying to like tom brady or not
anything like that i know it's not like
necessarily fair yeah so i think very
quickly like within the first like month
two months i think i'll have an idea
because the grind of the season you
can't really
you know imitate that
in your off season and that'll be the
story of like where i am so i think i'll
know pretty quickly